welcome to this video FM Wow Shania no
okay again the Trump I'm experimenting
yeah but people play six rather often
yeah this is supposed to be good or good
a good line for black yeah maybe did I
do something wrong here already I wonder
right here on my I can take and play
Bishop before hmm
hmm
okay it's a little bit difficult if you
have to really play it completely over
the board and don't know any any
anything should keep three queen bee
six-year the dark squares look weak it
looks like a bad advanced french for
white yeah I know that's not brilliant
but I really don't know what I should do
what's the best movie is or the best
approach I mean I can I can just play
this somewhat unambitious set up and
still claim to be okay i believe okay
come on let's just keep it really really
simple castles and f6 might be good or
f6 immediately f6 still would be a
problem but he's not going for it okay
hmm it's really surprising here I think
I'm okay it's nothing nothing brilliant
okay g5 is a movie app and so f for I
have to be a little bit cautious with
okay it's not he stopped going to take
on d4 I wonder about a 4 maybe I don't
know I want to win the game I have to do
something it's not really warranted oh
he's taking that's good news I mean you
can play a five now and he did to put my
points here my pony on a light square
I'm going to play for the before break
though okay so takes rook a three and
covering here or loops look a 3m and
then maybe you could be six intending
notes covering okay it's no reason not
to win a little bit of space here
rook could be six we should be five
something like that maybe King's pawn
drinks okay always let that be too quick
yeah both recaptures come into
consideration look at eight is a little
bit irritating let's let's take like
that maybe I have some chances for for a
breakthrough with f5 okay so g5 or what
no one's not doing that okay maybe can
hinder him a little bit here check I can
put it on d4 I wonder Bishop b5 I think
I have to oh look aged three very
embarrassing
now you can attack that a four-corner
that that's really really really
annoying
check if it takes f5 my intention is to
play six I hope this is working Bishop
is six rookie six it's a very simple
tactic I admit that China thought it
would would be active or here to e5
maybe yeah maybe here it sits in fact
interesting yeah I can take it to seven
maybe takes rook takes
for Bishop b5
time warning shapes hmm it doesn't work
ok so I have to go for this check on age
7 is the can I get this in
Kingda success is a check here Roxy 147
made and this assassin e7 made if this
is just a trick but it's not a bad one
how does it prevent it e seven bishops
rook c8 made how does he prevent that
Brooks is 77 I don't know this is
winning or something I don't see a
defense at the moment
rook a6 rook a six yes to pin me look a
six I will find that it's really the
only move and what did what is what am i
doing then Bishop d3 maybe and then back
back and try to win the pawn yeah okay
60 anymore should give three Wow push up
to 3 root p6 look-see 380 k 3 something
like that it seems it's not seeing the
move I didn't see it check this is main
route gay sex was the only only possible
move checkmate it's a little bit that's
funny right yeah I don't know sometimes
you see those things those tricks but
look crew k6 was really really the only
move another Oh am I am I totally blind
here rook a 64 the draw that's it's a
draw whoops this and and then a thought
here and rooks III this was my
calculation at least this this and
somewhere around here I don't know we we
fight on but he didn't see route 86 it
was really the only way to continue this
game otherwise I'm I think I'm just a
meeting him the way it happened in the
game
that was funny tricky tricky game I was
probably not in a good shape yeah but it
was mostly due to the cellar miss played
opening ok thanks for watching